البدايه من كارثه الزلزال التي حلت بتركيا
وسوريا وفي اخر تحديثات لارقام الضحايا
اعلنت اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه
افاد ارتفاع عدد قتل زلزال الذي ضرب جنوبي
البلاد الى ثلاثه الاف وثلاثمائه
وعدد المصابين الى عشرين الفا
وعشرين فيما اعلن المرصد السوري ارتفاع
عدد قاتل زلزال في سوريا الى
1580 ويواصل عمال الانقاذ في تركيا وسوريا
عمليه البحث عن ناجين بين انقاض الاف
المباني التي انهارت جراء سلسله زلازل
عنيفه هزت البلدين الامم المتحده مشاهدينا
كانت حذرت من ان اعداد الضحايا مرشحه
للارتفاع بقوه بسبب وجود الاف المباني
المنهاره كليا او جزئيا بينما تتواصل جهود
الاغاثه الدوريه واحدثها اعلان العراق فتح
جسر جوي الى تركيا وسوريا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]